[Music]
and now to our other big story
developing at fiverr awaiting a press
conference from metro police right now
regarding a barricade situation that
happened in the southwest valley us
believed to be a suspect in a deadly
shooting yeah the gunman shot and killed
a man at a gas station robindale jones
in the southwest valley we're going to
listen in now as we are getting an
update from ray spencer let's listen in
this morning's press conference we
pushed out photographs of the suspect
and we received a tip immediately after
this morning's press conference
detectives worked all throughout the
afternoon to validate the information
that was provided to detectives as a
result
we obtained a search warrant for a
residence directly behind me our swat
team was in the process of executing
that search warrant when that male
who is a 22 year old male walked out and
was taken into custody without incident
at this point we are in the process of
executing the search warrant inside the
residence and he has been taking the
metro headquarters where he is being
questioned so with that again
we are very thankful for the public's
assistance it is because of the public's
assistance and
outpouring that we were able to put this
case
or solve this case and arrest the
suspect i'll take a couple questions if
you have them
at this point i don't have the or i'm
not putting out the suspect's name he is
a male who's in his who is 22 years old
who lives at a residence directly behind
me later this evening we will
once he is formally booked at the clark
county detention center his name will be
made public
[Music]
the suspect's family was extremely
cooperative in the course of this
investigation so with working with the
suspect's family and information that
was provided that's how we were to take
the suspect into custody without
incident how many resources and how
immediate was the response to metro
throughout the day
well again we've been working on this
case all day we've had surveillance up
on this
house for several hours we were pretty
confident immediately after the tip that
came in this morning that we were
looking at the right suspect but again
just because we're provided a name we
had to do a lot more leg work to make
sure that we in fact had the right
suspect and now as a result of this
arrest we are confident we have the
right person in custody
i'm not going to get into the specifics
on who provided the tip a lot of people
neighbors over here saw him after
midnight
what he was doing
again
we'll get all those questions when we do
the interviews with him and hopefully in
speaking with family members and
neighbors at this point we are just
relieved that we have a very violent
criminal who committed a horrendous act
last night in custody and it is a result
of the public's assistance that were
able to make that arrest
real quick you just speak to how like
the situation with this violent
individual it could have been a
completely different direction it seems
like it ended pretty peacefully
considered right yeah and that's the
whole goal of all of our arrests is to
make sure that we can resolve the
situation peacefully you know obviously
when we bring swat resources we also
bring negotiators who are able to
negotiate a surrender but at this point
it didn't even get to that point he was
taken into custody
very quickly
one count obviously one count of open
murder and he'll face additional counts
for the actions of firing at the people
inside the convenience store
it was very brief as soon as you know
swat had made their arrival and started
setting up to
begin negotiations and make entry
that's when he came outside of the house
again that is lieutenant ray spencer
answering questions now about the search
for a gunman who was involved in a
deadly shooting at a convenience store
that suspect now in custody as you heard
there without incident that deadly
shooting happening overnight near jones
and robindale at a convenience store
we'll monitor that for you now